Співами проти ядерної зброї та атомної енергетики.
Понад 35 років активісти збиралися тут щомісяця 6-го числа,
протестуючи проти роботи АЕС у містечку Брокдорф на Півночі Німеччини.
Це 425-й і останній раз, коли вони мітингують тут незалежно від погоди.
Кінець цієї акції - це також і кінець атомної електростанції у Брокдорфі - однієї з найбільш суперечливих у Німеччині.
Нарешті її відключають від мережі.
Для співзасновника акції пастора Вернера це викликає змішані емоції.
Я радий, що АЕС відключають, але мені водночас трохи сумно,
бо я знаю, що незабаром ми вже більше не побачимося.
Зрештою переважує той факт, що атомна електростанція нарешті закінчить свою роботу.
Тоді ми не вірили, що доведеться тут так довго стояти.
Усе почалося у 70-80-х роках.
Студенти та активісти, особливо лівого спектру, сформували антиядерний рух.
Згодом у 1986 році сталася Чорнобильська катастрофа.
Величезна територія зазнала радіоактивного забруднення і досі непридатна для життя.
"Брокдорф" стала першою у світі атомною електростанцією, яку ввели в експлуатацію після аварії на ЧАЕС - восени 1986 року.
Сотні тисяч активістів протестували, відбулися жорсткі сутички з поліцією.
Пастор Вернер та його однодумці протестували мирно.
Я досі пам’ятаю Чорнобиль...
У мене були маленькі діти, яким не дозволяли гратися в пісочниці.
Ми всі були в паніці. Що насправді відбувається? Як це діє на нас?
Ми всі злякалися. І те, що допомагає проти власного ж страху, -
це насамперед розвинути опір і протестувати проти цього, діяти, щось робити.
Його страх перед радіацією не був безпідставним.
У 2008 році дослідження засвідчило, що є значно підвищений ризик захворювання дітей на лейкемію,
якщо вони виросли в безпосередній близькості від ядерних реакторів.
Це стосується і Брокдорфа. З появою АЕС селище розрослося, звели басейн, льодовий стадіон.
Тепер подібні проєкти вже в минулому.
Голова селища Ельке Ґьотше була проти закриття АЕС.
Ми як громада завжди підтримуємо наших підприємців.
Ми би хотіли залишити деякі атомні електростанції в мережі трохи довше,
поки не буде створено достатньо інфраструктури для відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Після аварії на "Фукусімі" Німеччина вирішила закрити всі атомні електростанції до кінця 2022 року.
При цьому багато інших країн продовжують робити ставку на атомну енергетику.
В цьому іміджевому фільмі французька атомна енергетика представлена як чиста і передусім екологічно нейтральна.
На цей аргумент спирається і французький президент.
Перш за все, щоб досягти кліматичної нейтральності до 2050 року,
ми вперше за десятиліття відновимо будівництво ядерних реакторів у нашій країні.
Справді, викиди в атмосферу від атомної енергетики нижчі, ніж від вугілля, нафти чи газу.
Однак якщо порівнювати з електрикою від вітру чи сонця, атомні технології набагато дорожчі.
Цілком зрозуміло, що ті країни світу, які найбільше віддані цивільній атомній енергетиці,
є або країнами з ядерною зброєю, або країнами, які явно зацікавлені в ядерній зброї.
Цивільне використання атомної енергії в багатьох випадках необхідно для реалізації військових програм ядерної зброї.
Франція та США навіть публічно заявили про це.
Якщо у вас немає цивільної атомної енергетики, інженерів, спецметалів, зварювальників,
ви не можете побудувати атомний підводний човен.
Так ці країни сприймають це, і є, приміром, абсолютно відверті звіти про це у США.
Тобто для цих країн, навіть якби атомна енергетика була вдвічі дорожчою, все одно був би сенс її розбудовувати.
Бо це допомагає виконувати військові зобов’язання.
Світ потребує електроенергії - чимдалі більше і максимально стабільної.
То яку роль насправді відіграє атомна енергетика?
Правда у тому, що вона значно небезпечніша, ніж відновлювана енергетика.
Але правда також і в тому, що порівняно з аваріями, пов’язаними з викопним паливом, таким як вугілля та газ, жертв було менше.
Тим не менше Німеччина вирішила відмовитися від атомної енергетики.
Я хочу сказати цілком відверто як прихильниця мирного використання ядерної енергії:
мій погляд на атомну енергетику змінився внаслідок подій у Японії.
Відмова Німеччини від атомної енергетики викликала подив у всьому світі.
Адже для захисту клімату слід також якомога швидше закрити вугільні електростанції.
А без атомної енергії це значно важче.
Перед нами - невідкладний і величезний виклик.
Ми справді не можемо дозволити таку розкіш і сказати "ні".
Тим не менше, кінець ери атомної енергетики також мав би свої плюси,
адже відновлювані джерела енергії значно розвинулися.
За останні 10 років їхня частка у виробництві електроенергії зросла з 20 до 50 відсотків.
Є два боки цієї проблеми. Ймовірно, Німеччина могла б скоротити свої викиди трохи швидше і дещо інакше.
Але поетапна відмова дала поштовх відновлюваним джерелам енергії не тільки в Німеччині, а й у всьому світі.
Зовсім іншим шляхом іде сусідня Франція, яка має понад 50 атомних електростанцій.
Але є проблема: багато з них вже застаріли.
Чим старішими стають атомні електростанції - тим вищий ризик аварій.
Ніхто не може гарантувати, що вони будуть працювати справно.
Адже атомні електростанції виробляють високорадіоактивні речовини.
Наприклад, плутоній, як тут на Півночі Франції.
Цьому величезному заводу вже понад 50 років.
Але майбутнє - зовсім не за такими спорудами.
Ідея полягає в тому, щоб розробляти реактори, які можна було б виготовляти промислово,
тобто автоматизувати на заводах.
Таким чином можна було б знизити ціну без втрати якості.
Нині, за умов кліматичної кризи, багато країн зробили ставку саме на атомну енергетику, будуючи нові АЕС.Особливо в Азії.
На думку критиків такого підходу, рішення про використання ядерної енергії - політичне, а не економічне.
Бо атомна енергетика дорожча за альтернативні джерела і не окупається для платників податків.
Скрізь енергоекономіка має значення, але не в атомній енергетиці.
Франція - традиційна ядерна держава. Економічно це було б катастрофою.
Французька група Electricité de France, якій доводиться нести тягар цієї програми,
має гору боргів у 40-45 мільярдів євро і буде врятована від банкрутства лише через заплановану націоналізацію.
Тема атомної енергії залишається дискусійною:
людству потрібно більше струму та менше викидів CO2.
Яку роль тут відіграє атомна енергетика - кожна країна поки вирішує сама...